hello
and welcome everybody
thank you all for joining us thank you
for coming
and welcome to how it's made the ritm
book edition
an event in which we'll celebrate and
hear from
three yale faculty members who have
authored important books in recent
months
i'm stephen pitty director of yale's
center for the study of race indigeneity
and transnational migration
and professor of history american
studies and ethnicity race and migration
i'm going to be moderating today's
conversation which should run a little
longer than
an hour since its founding in 2016 the
ritm center has worked to support
publications by students and faculty
and to organize uh events of interest on
the yale campus
in other academic settings and for a
wider group of groups of people who
aren't affiliated with a college or a
university
so i hope that you'll keep your eyes
open for news of other events and
opportunities through ritm
in the days and weeks to come if you
aren't already receiving
our weekly newsletter please sign up for
it today the link will be posted
soon in the chat i'm going to introduce
briefly our three speakers
in the order in which they'll be
discussing their books today
uh each of them will talk for five to
ten minutes
and then we'll open the floor to
questions so if you have a question for
one or more of our authors please post
it
in the q and a we are very
too eager from to hear eager to hear
from you and i know that our our authors
would love to respond to any questions
that you have
our first speaker today is laura
barakloff
the sarai ribacoff associate professor
of american studies at yale
laura is an interdisciplinary scholar of
land memory identity and
inequality in the united states she's
the author of
making the san fernando valley rural
landscapes
urban development and white privilege
and she's co-authored with laura polito
and wendy chang
of a people's guide to los angeles she
will be speaking today about her new
book
charros how mexican cowboys are
remapping
race and american identity published by
the university of california press
daniel martinez hosang is an associate
professor of
of ethnicity race and migration and
american studies with a secondary
appointment in the department of
political science at yale university
dan's work explores u.s political
culture in many sites including
electoral politics social movements and
cultural formations
he is the author of racial propositions
ballot initiatives in the making of
post-war california
and the co-editor of three books
including one entitled
seeing race again countering color
blindness across the disciplines
dan will be speaking today about his
recent book producers parasites patriots
race and the new right-wing politics of
procarity
which he co-authored with joseph lowndes
and which was published by the
university of minnesota press
our third speaker today is ana ramosas a
professor of ethnicity race and
migration
and of american studies and anthropology
at yale university
anna is the author of national
performances
class race and space in puerto rican
chicago and of
street therapists affect race and
neoliberal personhood
in latino newark she is also co-author
of latino crossings
mexicans puerto ricans and the politics
of race and citizenship and she has two
co-edited books that are forthcoming
dialogues critics and latino latina
studies
and whiteness in latin america and the
caribbean anna will be speaking today
about her recent book
entitled parenting empires class
whiteness and the moral economy of
privilege in latin america
which was recently published by duke
university press
and with that i'm going to turn this
over to laura and just ask laura to talk
a little bit about the making of her
book
charos how mexican cowboys are remapping
race
and american identity laura thank you so
much steve and and thanks to my
colleagues dan and anna for being here
this idea has been a long time in the
making and
um given kobe given the state of the
world it took us a while to be together
but i'm so happy to be here and to be in
celebration
and thank you all for coming um i'm
gonna try to share
my slides here one moment please
okay so i'm i'm speaking today as steve
mentioned from my new book
charos how mexican cowboys are remapping
race and american identity and in a
general sense the book is really
tracking
the various ways in which mexican
immigrant and mexican american
communities in the united states
have mobilized this extremely
significant figure
of the charo in pursuit of various um
political social and cultural
initiatives
in the united states um and so i just
want to briefly
explain what achara is or who acharo is
he is most probably most familiar to
to folks um because uh the character the
trajectory is worn by
mariachi musicians um but the charo that
i am writing about in the book
is uh related more um to the acts of
horseback riding and so
and branching and roping and rodeo so
the best translation of the word charo
might be mexican horsemen
um and you know just an aside that as
the publisher and i were deciding on the
title for the book
um in the subtitle is mexican cowboys
and
i think that's a partial translation but
it's not a great translation because
at least in the u.s the image we have of
a cowboy is of a kind of a working class
um isolated rough figure
and in mexico the the figure of the
charo is much more associated with the
elite with landowners
and with most of all probably most
significantly with highly skilled
dignified work on horses with other
ranch owners so it's it's much more of
an elite or a gentleman
the gentleman horseman might be a better
translation um and charros have a long
history in mexico 400 plus years it's a
figure that's associated with spanish
colonization
and it he really has um contested
divergent meanings so on the one hand he
has been associated with the elite in
mexico the spanish colonial elite
but he also has been associated with
nationalist revolutionary figures like
emiliano zapata and pancho villa
and so part of what i was interested in
are those struggles over what the
channel should mean
in terms of its class status and his
relationship to mexican nationalism
but the particular contribution of my
book was to
try to track the ways that those debates
had um been
uh carried out in the united states so
the charro is very very well studied
within mexico there's great critical
scholarship by mexican scholars a lot of
which i cite in the book but he had not
been the study of significant
scholarship in the us
and this is despite the fact that
charles have emerged as political actors
in the united states
um as early as the 1930s we did have a
couple of good ethnographies by
anthropologists that had been conducted
in the 1990s but there was really no
history of the ways that charles had
been used by mexican-american
communities
and so that was the purpose of of my
book how mexican communities in the u.s
have mobilized this complicated
and yet very significant figure for a
variety of social and political change
initiatives
um importantly my book was not an
ethnography
it is an analysis that is very much
public facing i was focused on how
ethnic mexican communities have tried to
impact various public institutions and
social structures
and to link that to the long history of
dispossession and racialization in the
united states
and sometimes that involved looking at
how general communities in the u.s
had challenged whitewashed mythologies
of ranching and rodeo and cowboys
in the americas um and so that is where
the the the idea of
of the subtitle how how these cowboys
again in
inadequate term um have remapped
american identity in part
by invoking this longer and hemispheric
history
of the charro um in in the u.s
so i used a variety of sources spanish
and english language newspapers
lots of archival collections deposited
in various us
institutions mostly in the southwest by
middle class mexican-american figures
who were involved
with general associations or
associations of men who ride and rope
together and compete together
a few interviews looking at legislative
documents school
curricula all kinds of things it's a
very interdisciplinary study and a lot
of this was about
place which we'll talk a little bit
about later on in our conversation
um and so i just want to show you some
of the the specific case studies that
the book is looking at
um i start in los angeles uh where the
focus was really on
the ways that the chatro became a
vehicle for mexican americans to
integrate the state and specifically the
los angeles sheriff's department
this is sheriff eugene b skyloos who
could trace his identity back to elite
california families
um and who dressed up as a charo as a as
the head of the los angeles sheriff's
department there was also a group of
working-class
mexican-americans from east l.a who
joined
the sheriff's posse in this period and
and this is in the 1940s and 1950s and i
think this is a really important
counterpart
to other studies of mexican americans
in l.a in the wartime era who were
mostly persecuted by
the police but in this case charles were
also
members of the police and you can see
that here they're um there
these are la sheriff's department posse
um charles in the background of this
photo
i also have a study of san antonio in
the 1940s and 50s
where the characters were much more
focused on the economy so these were
folks who were
part of the city's tiny tiny middle
class mexican-american middle class
but who were uniquely positioned to draw
on the image and the history of the
charo to build a bi-national tourist
economy drawing in investors from
northern mexico at a time when san
antonio was really trying to propel
its own urban growth and so that gave
them a degree of economic
leverage i also have um some some
materials on colorado
and in in my chapters on denver and
pueblo colorado i
um really am drawn to this person
leonard chuleda who was the first
hispana principal of denver public
schools
and who was centrally involved in the
work towards desegregation
bilingual education and culturally
responsive curriculum
in part by authoring a curriculum guide
called
the rodeo i'm sorry it's blocked by my
screen but it's it's rich spanish
mexican heritage and so for her in
in denver this the work of the charos
she was a charo
or a chara and um this really
influential local principal
um and again drew on the chatroom as a
source of empowerment for
spanish-speaking children
i also look at the ways that charidia or
mexican rodeo could be used to help
ethnic mexicans claim public space as
they were suburbanizing in los angeles
and to a lesser extent
suburbs of other southwestern cities and
here my hope was to
um show how suburbanization and
residential integration is not only
about private space but about struggles
for public space
and the expression of a cultural
identity as a way again of transforming
racialized structures
and i finished the book by looking at
the ways that charles have been caught
up in animal welfare legislation
several of the events in the mexican
rodeo have been
deeply contested and controversial and
they've been subject to a lot of
critique by
animal rights activists which has forced
them into the legislative sphere and so
my last chapter
looks at the ways that those debates
about animal welfare have have really
led
charles to scale up away from the local
level and become
national political actors regional and
national political actors in a way that
they become formal political subjects
i'm going to just close by saying
something about how i came to this
project and i'll
stop my screen share for a second so um
i came to this project
because i grew up in the suburbs of los
angeles in the 1980s and 1990s
um and this was a time as dan has
written about in his first book racial
propositions
um that was deeply deeply contentious
around issues of race and immigration
um the way that i experienced those was
that i grew up in a protected rural
neighborhood
in the city of los angeles where horse
keeping was protected
where the rights to keep chickens and
other farm animals was protected by city
government
and it was also a neighborhood that was
something like 90 percent
white at a time when the city of l.a was
becoming a majority latinx
and like less than 30 white at the
county level
and so i became very interested in the
relationships between the city's
protection of rural landscapes and the
unbelievably disproportionate whiteness
of that neighborhood
and so i wrote about that in my first
book making the san fernando valley
but it was also clear even in those
moments that
that was never the whole story and in
fact um for this book i was really
drawing on my own experiences as a child
growing up
riding around my neighborhood and and
meeting um out in public space
charos who were riding their horses
pridefully with dignity with skill
um and i also so i was able to see that
in in public space in my neighborhood my
majority white neighborhood
these were folks from adjacent
neighborhoods um but also i was able to
see
how threatened local white folks in my
neighborhood were by those
alternative histories of of horsemanship
and skill
and so this book was really about trying
to untangle
those those relationships and those
tensions and i'll just say
as a way of of wrapping up it has been
amazing to me to
to realize that i have spent the last 15
years of my life
and at least two books and some articles
basically trying to figure out
the tensions and the contradictions of
my childhood and i think that's one of
the things that ethnic studies
scholarship and scholarship
in general can allow us to do so thank
you very much i'll i'll pass it over to
dan thank you thanks so much laura um i
so appreciate
like in your work just how rigorous the
balance is between like history and
place based and it moves across all
these sites
and how you've just narrated its
connection to your own experiences so
um so uh just again thanks to steve and
ritm and folks are listening um
today and i'll just say you know in
terms of like
methodology for especially students
listening
if you're looking for good models and
examples please follow laura and anna
because the only methodology that i can
share here
is kind of looking at things politically
that have taken place in the last 10
years that relate to the kind of bottom
dropping out
it seems of our social life and economy
and fabric
and the ways they've intersected with
these kind of unusual
um developments uh connected to racial
politics so
i just thought to try to share some of
like how that worked for us
i would just share some of these images
and kind of talk about
um what for us were always just uh
questions on top of questions on top of
questions
um so this is the book uh producers
parasites and patriots
um and i i before i was yale i was at
the university of oregon for 10 years so
that's really where this took root um in
2012
right after the midterm elections um uh
my co-author joe lowndes and i trying to
figure out some of these developments
and i'll just
start with this since this group the
proud boys was mentioned
for those that might have watched the
presidential debates last night
so um a group that was started in 2016
by gavin mcinnis a
co-founder of vice magazine and media
which kind of represented itself as a
what they called was a western
chauvinist organization
so they certainly would disavow that
they were white supremacists as such
and yet constantly involved in
um not just kind of like street level
violence and
fight but actually they became the kind
of like street force of trumpism in the
aftermath of the election you'll see
here
these are photos from different proud
boys um gatherings and
you know what's startling here is the
the three-fingered okay symbol
which is now generally taken up to be a
symbol of white supremacy
um offered up by not just a a a
uh you know a man of color seemed to
like wandered into the photo
but uh men of color who uh seem much
more central to this project and so
uh part of what we know this is not all
of the book but uh you know
part of the book was thinking about what
we call the kind of
multi-racial or multicultural far-right
um that has emerged since 2016
that goes hand-in-hand with the most
white supremacist tendencies of the
trump administration
and of conservatism today um and yet we
you know from our perspective didn't
have good accounts to think about
kind of how this was happening or where
this came from so in the lower left
corner
this is a photo of the proud boys in um
new york city you'll see a photo on the
right um or an image of not only just
all these men of color but actually
like self-described um guatemalan
skinheads immigrant skinheads engaged in
immigrant bashing
in new york city so again a lot for us
to get our heads around
and i'll talk a little bit more about
where we ended up but these are some of
um
what we kind of took up i would say for
you know during the book we didn't
conduct too many interviews but
you know really the most kind of um
vexing moment was when we talked to
this figure in the middle joey gibson
who at the time was running for
um he was a kind of outsider uh
candidate for a
republican senate seat in washington um
and had just founded a group called uh
patriot prayer
which has been very very active uh in
these kind of street brawls in portland
and we asked him like well where do you
where did your politics come from like
who's influenced you
and gibson went on this long and very
serious and sincere account
of dr king of the greensboro lunch
counter sit-ins and their capacity
to withstand state violence and their
willingness to challenge it
he talked about the tragedy of the war
on drugs and again how the state
has reached in and disrupted the lives
of so many black families and
communities
he had a critique of big pharma and so
this was a strange you know we left the
interview like
is this just kind of mouthing um these
you know if
if you were a progressive and
self-identified kind of anti-racist
these would be predictable kind of
significations but for
gibson um he was really in this active
process of thinking about
how certain traditions of the civil
rights movement might be incorporated
into what was a very grassroots
far-right project
um so these are some of the topics we
take up in the book especially in the
latter chapters about the kind of
multiculturalism the far right we write
about this figure
um on the right sunny johnson who was a
close confidant of andrew breitbart of
breitbart
media very close to steve bannon a
movement builder within
very conservative circles has her own
weekly radio show on breitbart radio
that one can listen to if you have
serious satellite radio that i highly
highly recommend
she's really an anti-racist figure on
the right who has a vision of
that the far right might be cleansed of
the kind of uh
racial antagonisms that's been
associated with in the last 40 years in
particular
and that essentially black communities
could be the heart
of a new pro-business militarized
kind of anti-choice anti-feminist uh
right-wing project
um in which uh black people would be the
exemplars of those commitments
but they're just some other examples
images so that you know these groups
would often like go
to kind of typical liberal settings in
this case evergreen state
university um and you can see you know
these openly
islamophobic and violent it says united
states isis hunting permit
and then this kind of provocation yeah
we're a racist group that accepts
accepts members of all races but in fact
that's precisely what they are
they are a racist group on the far right
that is multiracial in some ways and it
reminds us
it's not like the critique is not just
well if the clan had a diversity
initiative and were more inclusive
then they would be you know kind of like
politically
in like there it's also the substance of
what they uh
talk about and that they're dynamic in
this way um this is enrique dario
afro-cuban based in miami who's the head
uh the nominal head of the proud boys
now um this is a picture with him and
roger stones again
showing a white power sign so how are
these sutures and these connections
being made in kind of real time just a
couple more images this is diamond and
silk who often have appeared on the
campaign trail with trump
helping shore up his kind of nativist
commitment suggesting
and this is certainly has no
correspondence to actual political
behavior
but um this argument that um you know
they have this line
clinton could do mass incarceration we
can do mass deportation
so uh very kind of tricky again kind of
suturings that are happening
and you know again another like whoa
what is going on this is
paul nieland who ran for a gop seat in
wisconsin
um and he was a pretty unapologetic
white supremacist he was like
you know they discovered these
connections he had and he kind of
admitted them
he had diamond and silk do a um a
commercial for him
which you know he used to try to talk
about protecting american jobs
his rabid all-white base loved the
appearance of diamond and silk
partly you know because it deflected
perhaps charges of um
their own racial animus but much more
because from their perspective they
really animated this vision
of a u.s nationalist militarized
nativist formation that could be
multiracial in that way and i don't want
to say this is not targeted in any way
towards black voters
this is for white voters on the far
right
this is steve bannon who we found
actually was continually making these
appeals and addresses
to black businessmen and conservatives
in particular about how once the kind of
era of globalism and u.s support for
um neoliberalism ended um hundreds of
billions of dollars could be invested
into black communities
and the attraction he got in that claim
um
and that while we're more familiar you
know people have seen kanye or candace
owens who's
actually a much different kind of figure
there is a small but
potent bench of uh black and latinx
conservatives in particular
who really have a vision for how a new
uh republican party might be built um in
the wake of this and or
as far to the right as trump this is
senator tim scott
beloved by white tea party members in
south carolina far more
than someone like lindsey graham mia
love a republican congresswoman
for four years this is her speaking at a
gun rights rally
in salt lake city you can see
confederate flags militia flags there
you know there i just want to share this
image it's a little distorted but this
is from a web graphic
um it says which is the party of
responsibility republican
it shows love by age 30 married two kids
saratoga spring council
this is sandra fluke who the democrats
had asked to um
uh testify around access to birth
control
and so in this vision um um
love is the producer the good um proper
patriotic subject
and fluke is the irresponsible kind of
feminist subject
who needs discipline so these are just
configurations we would not have
expected
i'll just end here this is kj kohl's
james she's now president a black woman
of the heritage foundation
really the conservative kind of like
compass um on the right
it continues to be as conservative as
you would imagine all white as you can
see in this photo but led by a long
time um kind of conservative movement
builder so i'll just wrap up to say
because i
felt like i wanted to say something by
way of like implications here
that the incorporation of people of
color on the right actually and
paradoxically makes white supremacy more
durable
it shores up and legitimates its core
features of militarism patriarchy
nationalism and hierarchy the
inevitability of hierarchy these
incorporations are really quite
central surprisingly to trumpism and
they can exist with trump's more open
white nationalist appeals and they are
not collapsing
under the weight of their own
contradictions and as we think
regardless of what happens in the
election all the kinds of
reconstructions and things that will
happen this is something that's not
going away and i'll just end
because we do talk about a lot of the
grassroots organizing that's happening
on the other side
to reimagine and rebuild social
relations that could
um contest this uh particularly in rural
areas this wonderful group the rural
organizing project okay so that's just a
snapshot and
as chaotic and frenzied as i sound
that's partly
our methodology in the book and i'm
gonna turn it over to you so they can
hear about a proper academic project
i don't know about the proper academic
project but it's been wonderful to hear
both uh laura
and dan's uh work um oftentimes even
though we
share meetings and all of that we have
very little time to
really share our respective um academic
projects so
this is really a treat um so
my book is really almost like an outlier
in terms of my broader work that i've
done throughout my academic life and
most of the time
in most of the other work i focused on
working class latinx
communities in chicago and in newark
and that has been really the center of
the work that i started doing as part of
my graduate
dissertation my doctoral dissertation
and all the way
until about 2012 when i decided to
explore the other side of inequality and
started to try to understand not only
how
inequality damages the possibilities of
some but also how it
actually benefits others and to do that
i decided to do an ethnography
um that involved participant observation
interviews and lots of different
methodologies including some archival
work
um and it is a comparative ethnography
um of two neighborhoods two elite
wealthy
uh mostly white neighborhoods one of
them is ipanema in rio de janeiro
and the other one is el condado in
puerto rico
and there i spent about a month in each
um
in each place um and my friends were
really
um joking with me about it they were
like oh wow you went from walking the
streets of newark
um to like really hanging out at the
beaches of the caribbean
and you know the atlantic coast of south
america
and so and the truth was that um a lot
of times anthropologists and
ethnographers are associated with
um deep hanging out what we call deep
hanging out
so part of the research that you do
really involves trying to not only
interview people but see if what they do
in practice
actually uh supports what they tell you
that they do right so that's part of why
we spend so much time with people
one of the things that i wanted to the
reason why i chose um there were several
reasons why i chose these two
specific sites but what i found
interesting since we're talking about
the actual
um you know the background of book
making
uh is that i got quite a bit of pushback
uh
for assuming puerto rico to be part of
the latin american
and caribbean geography rather than
being part of the us
um they there was a very strong push for
me to turn this book
into a u.s brazil comparison
even if i did it through puerto rico and
i had to really push back against that
and i felt very strongly that i just
wanted to remove puerto rico for
from this side of exceptionalism where
it's neither covered by american studies
oftentimes or by latin american studies
because both of them feel that it
doesn't fit quite into either one
so mostly i did my work among very
wealthy
parents and the reason why i chose
parenting was because i really wanted to
study not people's necessarily
income or economic wealth in in a
traditional
marxist sense but also
in terms of how they made the decisions
around money
and around resources moral how do they
explain that they have so much more than
others um it was a really challenging
project
because i really all the time i was
trying not to
judge which is part of what we tried you
know in anthropology we try to sort of
um step back and let people be who they
are and sort of analyze
what we get there although that's always
not it's not always possible
so um i so one of the things that that i
that i did that i found out was
also a contradiction like when dan was
talking it made me realize that it was
really a big contradiction i mean
here we have very wealthy parents who
are very anti-consumption
they really don't want their kids to
have everything they're very selective
in terms of
what they give to children so they're
actually not the people that you would
think they are
they're not i think i went in there
expecting you know all this very
compass and people just wearing all
these brand names and all these other
things
and in reality they were not at all they
they were the kind of people that were
very invested in what i call
inner inner world cultivation which
means that they
develop their whiteness as an
interiority project
um and so so whiteness for them
is not necessarily about displaying
certain
fashion or certain body practices but
also about being able to express who
they are
as people and so um so
there were um several things that
sort of that were um
difficult to put up i mean to to like
sort of exert in terms of the
actual project of writing the book and
turning this project into a book
um i think one of the main
ones that happened very later on in the
process was even the choice of the cover
um so the cover was a back and forth
fight um with whoever decides on covers
at the press
and by the way i worked uh i worked with
these latinx
editors two of them i was like so
blessed
with that i was just like really they
were exceptional
but you know when you're dealing with
the with the presence there are a lot of
different departments and i remember
the insistence that i put a nanny
and a child in the cover and for me
i really wanted this to be about the
wealthy parents
because a lot of times what happens in
anthropological work is that we protect
um you know we protect the wealthy and
very much
analyze the poor and working classes so
um what i wanted was to make sure that
they understood this is not a project
about the nannies this is
actually a project about the wealthy
people and i just wanted wealthy people
in the cover and of course i
didn't i turned out to be that diva
because everybody you know like thinks
then like oh my god she's just like hey
whatever
but anyway so in the end um that worked
out and
you know that was one of the things that
i kind of really much insisted on
um i think one of the main
issues with a project like this which is
ethnographic is that you bring
your biography with you and of course
that's true in every project
uh to some degree or another um in this
particular case
it was really a tough
project to be part of not for the reason
you know like
it was it was tough because obviously
the entrance piece of like trying to
to get in touch with people that are
this wealthy the wealthy are very
protected
so how do you get in touch with them um
once
that is is obtained when
that happens one of the things that
becomes really difficult
is to try to learn to be at ease with
this particular crowd
that you are working with and um
and you know that are your interlocutors
and
um and so that those are uh parts
of the project that i work through out
um of course you know i was very aware
of where
the nodules of uh privilege
where in in the el condado site since i
grew up in puerto rico
um and i grew up in not in any of the in
any of those circles but i knew of them
like you know everybody was kind of new
where the good schools were and where
the
country clubs were and all of that and
then in brazil the challenges actually
were different because i was very
accepted as somebody who was not from
there
um so everybody wanted to show me their
lives but at the same time it was also
this kind of um
consistently trying to understand people
for who they were in the context that
they were you know what they were
showing me and at the same time develop
an analytical
take on them on the on the project so um
i
see both of the a lot of people have
asked me you know why
um brazil is such a big country puerto
rico such a small
you know like all these other things and
i explained um in the book i
spent quite some time explaining why i
feel that these units the neighborhood
units are
um comparable i don't know how to share
my powerpoint but let me see if i can
just oh okay
actually that's pretty yeah so i just
i'm not gonna share very much
um very many of the
of this of these slides i just wanna
show
um the cover um that i
that i chose but i also want to show the
similarities of the two neighborhoods
that
i focus on so on the left
um there is i wish i could point but so
on the left is a gondalo you can see
there is a lagoon
where a lot of the wealthy people spend
their time
kayaking doing water sports all of that
at the other side is the atlantic ocean
and the beach
and that also created some luxury
culture that was very very much present
among these elites and in their
parenting the same
ini panema on the right if you look at
both places from the top there's quite a
bit of similarities in the landscapes of
each
and one of the things that that i center
on
is how does this geography this
particular geography that it's
that has become associated with wellness
and healthy living and fitness and all
these other things
gets um enters the world of parenting
um one thing also that i wanted to
examine
through the lens of parenting was the
bigger question of sovereignty
and also of um
of the language of corruption and so
um so that became very evident once i
was talking to people at this point both
in brazil and puerto rico there were
some
um the countries were in in a severe
economic crisis
um most people talked about the
government in terms of corruption
and all of that language became
intertwined with what how people view
their way of raising children and of
course you know when you put children in
the picture
anything becomes justified and that's
part of why
child talking you know talking about
your children
is particularly powerful because you
know nobody will criticize these wealthy
people for one to be
um for wanting to do to
you know to protect their children um
so i think that's all that i want to
that i that i want to share let me see
i don't know how i get out of the
sharing i just do this
oh no sorry sorry about that
um so yeah so i'm looking forward to
hear your questions
thank you anna and thank you dan and
thank you laura
for these presentations i'm going to
remind
our audience members if you have a
question to please put them in the q a
and we'll do our best to get to as many
of them as we can
um you know uh anna you you you shared
with us a bit of the geography
of ipanema and i wanted to take that
question of sense to laura who
of course is is a geographer and her
book as she mentioned briefly
covers a lot of territory and it thinks
comparatively about chadros
and their practices in a number of
different places california texas
colorado as you mentioned but also
oklahoma kansas and nevada and perhaps
elsewhere
so laura maybe you could talk a little
bit about um
how your book uses a comparative
geographical approach
um and you know what the challenges of
of that approach were for you and the
importance of that approach
were in the writing of this book thank
you
yeah um i should say that when i first
started this book i
i had no idea where it was gonna go
geographically i had one story i had
stumbled upon in the archives about a
group of
suburban charros in los angeles in the
1970s but
i didn't i didn't know how to i didn't
know how that was going to become a book
it was clear that that story alone was
not
the book um as i started to share the
project
and just that the general interest in
genres with friends with colleagues with
family members
they started to send me newspaper
articles or things that they had found
in the archives
and that led me to places like san
antonio that i really had
very little knowledge about um and then
sent me to denver and i started just
stumbling across these things and it
it became very clear to me that the
chatroos in these various places were
not
the same um they were not the same kind
of people in terms of class status in
some places they were working class
in some places they were middle class in
some places they were mostly
immigrants in other places they had
their families had been in the u.s like
in new mexico since the
1700s and so um i at first was really
quite overwhelmed by trying to make
sense of this how this figure had been
used in so many different ways
by such different groups of people i
started to wonder how those differences
that i was observing might relate to the
specific geographies of ethnic mexican
people
in different parts of the us um and i
wanted i
eventually came to the conclusion that
whatever chattaria and the activism of
charles looked like in different places
was in almost all cases related to the
specific processes through which ethnic
mexicans had been subjugated in those
places so in san antonio it made sense
to me
it later made sense to me that the focus
was on the economy because of the
violence of the economy in south texas
and the fact that that ethnic mexican
people had been so confined to farm
labor for example
um and so whereas in in denver it took
the form of education for a variety of
reasons
um and so for me that became the project
was to try to explain how and why
the the activism around the channel
looked so different as a way to
map out the different trajectories of
ethnic mexican people in various places
across the united states and i think
this is something that we see a little
bit
in latinx studies for for other figures
like the bracero or the pachuco you know
um
and but that i i would like to see more
of because we know for example
um lalo likon who's at university of
wisconsin did a little bit of work for
example on pachuco's in tucson and how
that was different in los angeles i
think this is something that we that's
really important to think about
um when we're studying any racialized
community um
the challenge of this uh was that i did
not have lived experience
in most of these places the la chapters
were super easy to well
a book chapter is never that easy to
write but they were much easier to write
um the other places sometimes i had
never been to or i'd only been to for a
few hours and so
um what i i did was i read deeply
for graduate students on the on the
webinar or
people who have been graduate students
it felt like i was doing an orals field
for each of these places you know i
spent a year
reading about colorado ethnic mexican
people in colorado i
um tried to spend time in those places
whenever i could i spent one memorable
day
in pueblo colorado which was not enough
but it was really important to get to
these places and to feel them
to feel what the land this sounds cheesy
but to feel what the land feels like
there
um and the spatial arrangements of
things and to try to understand how that
might have affected
um the ways that that folks were
mobilizing in the past
and finally i tried to talk to people
who were from those places you know
one day i took the train down from
yale's campus to grand central station
and met with maria montoya um a
historian
uh western historian who's now at nyu
and and i just
she i was like did i get it right did i
get colorado right
and i asked you know for her honest
feedback on that but it
i think that was the hardest part of it
was trying to learn about all these
different places and their different
histories of racialization and
subjugation and dispossession but also
political activism and to feel you know
some degree of confidence
in articulating those different
histories
thanks laura dan let me let me ask you a
question that may be in part about your
methodology and
it may also address a question that came
in through the q a
um you know you're you worked on a
collaborative project that was also
a project that was unfolding in real
time and we of course saw this last
night in the debate
these issues foregrounded centrally by
the current president
i'd love to hear you talk a little bit
about the methodology that you used with
your co-author and
and how you approached this project um
uh studying things that really were
unfolding around you even as you were
trying to make sense of them
yeah thank you c for that um question um
i mean just on the uh collaborative part
um i was working on this at the same
time as several edited volumes and i
i've just
um i'm back to writing something my own
now and i just found collaborative
writing to be so um it kind of just
opened up so many possibilities and i've
just thought a little bit more about why
and part is there's just a built-in
accountability when you're writing
together to be constantly engaged with
one another
there's something also about it the way
it treats writing it's always an
open-ended practice so you can write
something
share it get feedback add something so
the sense that everything you produce
has to be finished and complete
tends to diminish and there's just an
active way in which thinking and writing
together
when you're in conversation just really
for me opened up a writing process so
we would often do this back and forth
because my co-author was in oregon and i
was in connecticut
through texts through other you know
short emails but i realized that was
part of the thinking these very
short efforts to try to offer a take and
it just speaks to the second question i
mean we were trying to a different point
to write about
the militia occupation that was
happening in eastern oregon in late 2016
all of these uh uh kind of some
conflicts that were happening in
portland
so in that sense these very kind of
shorter exchanges
in which we were trying to just get our
heads around things um
really with a certain kind of writing
methodology and the last thing i'll just
say about the chaos is i mean i so
appreciate what laura's saying about
this
um effort to you know get things right
to feel like you're accurately
representing you're spending enough time
where you can
you're not just leaping to a conclusion
for us i think we were relieved of some
of that because as things were happening
there were other people writing in much
more
comprehensive and longer term ways based
on interviews we wanted to try to think
about
certain kinds of like just takes
impressions
that when we were putting things
together so for me at least i felt a
little freed from some of that that
there would be other scholars
really trying to offer the kind of
definitive archival account
of these episodes and we could focus in
some ways on the politics of them and
their implications
great thank you um ana let me let me
turn to you we have a question in the
chat about
um publishing one's first book and then
publishing a second book and what you
might say to yourself
now back then when you were working on
your first book having
since then had some experience with
publishing could you talk about some of
the similarities and differences between
or working on your first project and
seeing it through to publication and
working on this
project and seeing it through the
publication
yes and that's a great question and it
makes me reflect on on two moments of my
life that we're completely different i
mean and i think that
the book and the publication is very
much informed
by what what what predates that process
right like
where you are in your life in that
moment
my first book which was in puerto rican
chicago um
the experience of doing field work in
among
the activists in puerto rican chicago
simply changed my life and shaped
who i became as a human being that's not
the same thing
and and that is reflected in the kind of
writing that i did it was very difficult
for me
to remain um critical of anything that i
was looking at i mean it remained
i i had like a stronger sense to please
an audience i felt that it was very
tough to write that book from a very
emotional perspective
and i didn't know how books work i mean
i was one of these people that i i just
like had no idea like what do i do
so i just started calling presses it's
like oh i'll just call university of
chicago i'll call this other one
and it turned out that i mean i one of
those lucky moments like i called the
university of chicago
and the the secretary to the editor
of anthropology and sociology at the
time david brent just picked up and he's
like oh he's here
so i just pitched the thing in two
sentences he's like oh
yeah so i'm doing this and he's like
yeah send me you know send me
um the whole thing so that freaked me
out it's like oh my god you're not gonna
ask for a proposal
send me the whole thing so the whole
thing wasn't ready obviously because
why would you know i just i'm just
checking and calling so i just tried to
put it together and just send it
um i feel that and and and that was a
wonderful first experience i think
it's very rare that things happen that
way now um this is back in 2000
i think around there and so for the late
the last book i felt it was
my interest in the book was academic and
it was
out of certain careers curiosity about
having become a mother at the time
and feeling completely overwhelmed not
by raising a child
but by the social pressures of other
parents
so it became being in this hell of like
new york city parenting and i said you
know i need to first i need to get out
of this health so
let's get out of new york and the us as
far as i mean
and secondly you know i cannot just get
out of the hell i need to bring my child
with me to the hell
because i can't you know have a child
now and so this became
something that began in terms of trying
to
understand that reality and the pressure
and the awfulness like
generally like becoming an awful person
moments
because of this role that i was feeling
and understanding that this role is not
about my own
psychological existence there is this
very very structural element to what
parenting
looks like and trying to understand that
so by the time that i was writing that i
was coming together
that i was coming up with the book what
really
um sort of um was in my head most is
like
how much these parents resemble
my friends myself and my friends
oftentimes right
and so is coming to terms with that with
that contradiction of
you know i'm critical of these people
but we are all part of this
and we are also staying in this how do
we dismantle it because obviously all
this is doing is enhancing
inequality um even if it's unintentional
whatever
and so so for that in that um i i also
got very lucky with this but i i did
have a book proposal already just
because i needed to organize my thoughts
you know once you come back from
from field work you have 20 million
mp you know like all these um trans
interviews to transcribe
fieldwork field notes you have like tons
and tons and tons of documents and a way
for me to get it together a little bit
was to organize it in a book proposal
format
and then i just reach out to duke um
because i had one i had liked some work
that they had done and
um and i touched base with gisela fosado
this
amazing editor and it was a joy from
then on but yeah but
the two were very different and um and i
appreciate that question
thanks anna um so you've talked a little
bit about the reception of your work
by by editors both at chicago and at
duke
um and dan i know you need to leave a
little earlier than the other panelists
so i want to ask you a question about
the reception of your work
you can take this in a direction that
talks about how you worked with the
press if you'd like to but i actually
wanted to ask you more generally about
how you see the book
um doing work in the world um since its
publication
who you think has read it if you've
gotten any feedback from it who you'd
like to see read it
and what you'd like to see is the impact
of the book yeah thank you steve for
that question
you know for me the most gratifying ways
to connect to readers have been um
talks we've been able to give with some
labor unions community-based
organizations
um and other sites which has involved
what
you know i think this is the rich work
of trying to figure out the relevance
of the material and its insights to
people's active
organizing understandings of the
political landscape etc
so those have been the most satisfying i
think the more challenging part there's
been
two things one is to write a book that
feels like rigorous enough for our
colleague our academic colleagues that
draws on literature
relevant literature while making it
accessible to a wider audience and i
have to say that's that's
difficult to do and something we
struggled with and i still struggle with
um the other part i think has been like
how to not just turn these into
um a lot of the interviews we did they
were kind of like can you talk to us
about these odd characters
and offer some insight into their
psychology which was not the point of
the book
and part of what i realized is that kind
of taken out of context
that's that's part of what people can
think that the work was about so just
kind of like
um funny people who like are
i've lost their uh orientation so i
guess i i'm saying that's
for us been part of a balance between
you know trying to remain faithful to
some of what we hope is like the rigor
in the book and the analysis
and that it's pushing while also having
it feel like it's
accessible in places and that it's been
easier so when we're in the same room
talking to people about it
um listening from them getting ideas
from them and that's also been the most
satisfying part of it as well
great thank you um laura let me ask you
then a version of that same question
just you know how you see your book
working in the world if you
if it's had a life since it was
published last year
if you have any sense about how it's
been received since it was published
um i i do thank you for asking i i think
one of the things that i i learned from
my first book to answer the previous
question that i
didn't expect but i i was able to expect
it this second time around is that
as authors you know we work on these
things for many years and then we send
them out in the world and there's a
feeling that we are done
but in fact that is the first time that
the rest of the world is seeing it and
so that's actually in many ways like
the beginning of the book's life um and
that can be difficult actually like
i i turned this book in and i was
exhausted and did not want to think
about it for a while and then you know
the
press requests start rolling in so um so
that is something to think about for
those of you who are are publishing your
first
book um or really any book um for me
some of the the
i i think of a few things one is that um
i was able to
include photographs by a really
incredible san antonio-based
photographer al rendon
as he graciously gave me permission to
use images on the cover of the book and
i have in the book this photographic
interlude
mostly with photos taken by him that
tries to
just explain what the different events
are in the chatriada
um and for me one of the things that was
most gratifying when the book was
published was to see him promote it on
facebook because of how meaningful it
was for him
as a photographer who had spent like a
decade of his life photographing these
communities and so
i hadn't really intended that but to see
the ways that he
and then i later started to hear about
so many people who
learned about their families um through
these learned about their communities
uh saw their communities in this book
and that was really gratifying as as one
example which is probably my favorite
story to share about this
after i um maybe like six months ago i
got an email from a chicano woman in san
diego who told me
that she found my book on amazon because
she's not an academic
she found my woman my book on amazon
because she was going to redecorate her
living room
in charo and ranch style decor
and was searching on amazon for charros
and
there popped up my book and she so that
alone is amazing right that people might
find our work when they're not looking
for anything academic
but she bought it and she read it and in
the very first chapter
she um saw her father she read about her
father
and her uncle and some of her neighbors
and then
she wrote to me and she was like oh my
gosh you know like i can't believe it
and then
she sent me photos um that i you know
and it was
because i didn't do a lot of interviews
or and i didn't do ethnography for this
book
um it was just like to to hear that the
book could be useful that it could
connect with the people who were who i
was trying to represent using other
kinds of sources
was super um super it just
it just made me glad i had done it you
know even though the book was
challenging in so many ways and then one
last thing that i'll add is that
i am now um copied on virtually every
email that charles
sends to their legislators um you know
i'm in a long list of bcc's or cc's you
know
and that's why i think that they see me
as at least somebody who is following
and tracking what they do which i
which i am and that's it's just been
super interesting none of those things
are things i would have predicted and
they go
well beyond the academic circles that i
was probably writing for
primarily anna i know you've you wrote
your book
i think it's fair to say primarily for
academic audiences
um but i wonder if you also had your own
interlocutors
in mind as potential readers and if you
could talk about how you see your book
being read and
what kinds of responses you've received
thus far
yes i'm thinking when i was listening to
laura i'm thinking of my first book
the book of puerto rican chicago that
became a study book for the
for the for the very activists which
were part of the book
um so they would meet and book clubs i
mean these were very um
a group that was very much aware of how
history mattered
in the present um and so so
that was i think that was for me a very
unusual i mean the fact that the very
people who were on the book
are really and of course they they could
tell who was what and that caused all
sorts of other things
even though i had tried to conceal um a
lot and you know
this current book came out on the same
day that we went on lockdown in new york
so all the different kinds of
presentations all the different kinds of
things that i wanted i wanted to send
books to some people that
had been in the book and all that kind
of got stopped so
the most that i've been able to tell in
terms of impact
um well impacts in academic settings
yes i mean i've gotten you know
mostly in terms of visits to
pretty much i mean um you know india
uk i mean just like a whole bunch of
places which surprised me
but that's those are academic settings
but in terms of how it's actually
impacted like i think more of the people
that were in the book because this is an
ethnographic book so
you know you always wonder and i know
that the people in this book
specifically will read the book um
and one of them has already read the
book and she has been texting me
about you know wanting to learn more
about her own white privilege which is
very interesting i'm just like wow but
you know and i've told her you know when
i go to puerto rico we can just get
together and talk about this because
right now we're on whatsapp and that's
like a lot of texting
but um but you know but but but it was
really interesting to hear her
her reflection on it and like what she
got out of it
um at that point she was halfway through
so
i haven't heard from her since she
finished i don't know if i said anything
like
more objectionable in the last part of
it um
but i'm actually and then another person
from from brazil who works
um you know who's very always been very
interested in
in just child experts and stuff like
that
also wanted me to give a talk um
for one of her organizations so there
have been initiatives like that at this
point
um and all of that has been sort of
colored by covet
but um but yeah but it's always like
especially for interpol you know for
ethnography it's just very interesting
to see what their reaction is not only
for the broader
um academic population but also for the
people that
feel that they're in the book so yeah
great thank you let me ask all three of
you a final question and you can take
this
in whatever way you want um and tailor
it to your own project
i mean it strikes me that for each of
you um the project that you're
discussing
had was in some ways familiar um to
to you in advance whether it connected
with uh personal interests and personal
experiences or in some way had
relationships to past projects
that you had done but there are other
ways in which each of your projects
you know represented something
significantly new uh
and you know i'm thinking especially
both for for dan and for anna working
with populations i think that you had
not worked in quite this way
academically before so i'd love to hear
all three of you talk a little bit about
how you oriented yourself to this new
material how you thought about your
responsibilities to representing
um the the actors and protagonists and
people you were discussing in this work
and
what you felt to be the kind of key
challenges that you'd like to share with
other people
and taking on a project that was in some
ways new and in which you may have you
know
been working with with groups of people
um with whom you didn't share
um all ways of life and all ways of
thinking um
so you know dan since again i know
you're going to need to take off a
little earlier maybe we could start with
you
um and then go to anna and and then
finish with laura
sure great um thanks steve for that
question i mean
i think you know i i spent a lot we
spent a lot of time for this project we
were at militia rallies
um you know endless hours listening to
right-wing radio
on those sites um and i think what i
felt like
i was trying to do there was you know
one really understand the kind of like
logic the commitments
the world view listening for the
openness to it so it's not just that i'm
i already know the kind of narratives
and
positions that people hold and embrace
and certainly without um then
underestimating its violence it's the
potential harm that it had um
you know the day we interviewed joey
gibson the next day he was a part of a
very vicious
you know kind of brawl so we were on the
one hand trying to offer
you know a nuanced account of the
conversation we had with him while
saying
this that's not meant to minimize uh
everything he's done and just
the last thing i'll say is you know i'm
doing a project now on this right-wing
radio host sunny johnson
there are long periods of time when i
listen to her
when she's
totally criticizing lecturing
white conservatives about their racism
and
i strangely identify with her like
anti-racist commitments that she's
trying to enact
even though that anti-racism is in
service of a far
different vision so i actually i don't
seem to then say this like see all the
connections we can make
as much as just that these like ideas
and possibilities are not somehow like
just
the sole possession of people who i
connect with and identify with if those
ideas are out there in the world
they may have come from our communities
and intellectual traditions but many
many people are taking them up
and i think that has to be taken
seriously otherwise all you do is just
dismiss it and say
you know you shouldn't even be having
this conversation so um
i uh that's partly what i've learned
here
thank you great i mean just listening to
that i like i
can you know it reminds me of like all
this
conversation about cultural
appropriation and to what degree are
these debates becoming this culturally
appropriated
like possibly appropriated um phenomenon
um so i think that's even though um yes
these populations were different from
what i've used
what i've done what the kind of work
that i've done before i've always really
been interested in how psychology
operates in a sociological way i mean
like how
therapy psychology affect even
acquire a material life and i think that
that continues into this project in that
sense is not super different from
that other kind of project what was
different and was very helpful
is to understand how latino latinx
studies and latin american studies
need to be examined in junction they
need to be examined together i mean
there is so much
wealth of materials on both sides that
will benefit
our reading of of the other um
so that actually led to the next the
edited volume that steve mentioned on
like this handbook of latinx studies
that i'm
doing with my colleague and friend
um so so one of the things that i felt
that came out of that process of the
of the book that that you know that i
that hadn't come from previous work
was the clarity of those connections and
those points of
of of convergence between the fields um
so i would say that that had been
something that i i
will continue to think through and try
to implement not only my research but
also in my teaching and the classes that
i put together
because i am very interested in
making sure that in classroom
discussions
we we have we have the grasp
of a broader body of literature even
when the class is latinx studies
or latin american studies as it may be
so
yeah wait um for me that this question
about how do we it's a
i hear it partly is how do we study
communities that we're not fully members
of
um and that was that was a complicated
thing for me
that mostly came down to the methods
that i chose for this book so my first
book i had done
deep hanging out of the kind that ana is
talking about i wrote about the
community that i grew up in i went to
four years
of really difficult and painful
homeowners association meetings i was
writing about white folks that i grew up
with
mostly white women um and the way that
they thought about land
and um in that sense that was a very
personal book so for the second book
though
um i was writing about people who lived
in nearby neighborhoods but were men
were older men were mexican-american or
mexican immigrant
um and so i had to think really hard
methodologically how could i offer
something useful
um and it became clear to me pretty
quickly that i could not and did not
want to do ethnography
um and that was hard for me for a little
while to kind of wrap my head around
because i had been so committed to
ethnography in the first book
um i think it was also important to say
you know there were
logistical things here that any of us
has to think about i
moved to the east coast um there are
some
rodeo and vaquero scenes here but
they're not charros and they they
it's not the place that i was trying to
write about so logistically
um it became really difficult for me to
imagine doing deep ethnography with the
folks that i was writing about but also
there had been and there still are
uh pretty um active animal welfare
campaigns directed at charros and they
are led by people who look like me
white women middle aged who grew up with
animals and so it was actually
difficult for me to gain access um and i
i worry that if i had chosen to do a
different kind of method that
so much of the work would have been
charros trying to convince me to be
their ally and their advocate
in animal welfare debates and and the
two interactions that i did have that
were
um interviews uh deep longer interviews
both took that direction really quickly
and so i had to step back from that and
figure out a different method that could
still
allow me to answer the questions that i
was curious about
but also that could be useful to the
scholarship
and so i really thought about a lot of
this book was writing in service to and
to try to be useful to
my own mentors who were mostly in
chicago studies um
and to try to do something that could be
useful to them and to the field
and it also became about writing
something useful for the
for the communities that i was writing
about but that was not ethnographic and
again that was where i was able to
identify that
there was no history of these
communities in the united states there
were there were a few ethnographies
there was no history
um and there was no comparative
geography and so i i
i landed on that and i i feel okay about
that
um even though it was such a different
thing from my first project it became
necessary because of my own subjectivity
my own location geographically subject
location in relationship to the folks i
was writing about
and i think the larger lesson that that
taught me which has become important as
i've matured a bit as a scholar is
to really um acknowledge and embrace the
fact that we can
use very different methods for different
projects and that we can feel
differently about our projects um the
first
book was very personal the second book
was less so it was more professional
um or i pursued it for more sort of
professional and political reasons
um and that that in our long life span
hopefully we would get to work on more
than one project but that
that there's room for all of that and
that we can do different kinds of work
at different moments in our life
depending on
how we're positioned and who we're in
relationship with
thank you laura and thank you anna and
thank you dan i think that's a great
place to close i
so appreciate the opportunity to hear
from all three of you
about how your books were made and again
for our audience members to our audience
members thank you for coming you can see
the
the titles of these books and some more
information about them
um in the chat if you're interested uh
laura berkoff's book is
chadros how mexican cowboys are
remapping race and american identity
dan hosang's book is producers parasites
patriots race and the new right-wing
politics of procarity
uh and uh ana ramosa's book is
parenting empires class whiteness and
the moral economy of privilege in latin
america
this has been a great conversation i
really appreciated hearing about the
contents of the book but perhaps more
importantly
how you envisioned these books and and
how you pursued these topics and how you
carried them out and how they were
ultimately made
so thank you so much for being with us
today panelists and attendees and we
hope to see you soon at an ritm event
take care